OK, so we already looked at Steve Scalise
turning a question about Marjorie Taylor Green's
outrageous comments into an answer about China,
Joe Biden and carbon.
Let's now go to our second example of the
day.
This is Republican Congresswoman Nancy Mace
asked on Fox News about the ludicrous things
that Marjorie Taylor Green has said.
Remember, we've uncovered videos of Marjorie
Taylor Green talking about Jewish space lasers
as the cause for California wildfires.
Marjorie Taylor Green being a 9/11 denier.
Marjorie Taylor Green talking about political
violence as a good thing, as something that
that needs to be done on and on and on.
Republicans are being asked to comment.
Nancy Mace is a Republican congresswoman from
South Carolina.
Some believed not me, but some believed that
she was a more moderate, rational voice in
the Republican Party.
She went on Fox News yesterday.
She was asked about Marjorie Taylor Green's
comments and she actually to her credit, she
seemed to concede that Marjorie Taylor Green
is crazy, but she played the both sides game
saying there are crazy people on both sides
and then gave a number of false equivalency.
So let's take a look.
There are crazies on both sides of the aisle.
We've seen that.
You know, it's not just Republicans that have
our own issues where Democrats have them,
too.
We've seen Maxine Waters tell folks to go
and threaten and harm members of the Trump
administration.
Right.
We've seen crazies on both sides of the aisle.
We do have to, I think, address some of these
issues.
But, you know, some of these things and I'm
learning about them today.
And this week, two were said before she was
elected and Georgia voters still elected her.
Just a few years ago, we saw Democrat, another
Democrat from Georgia, Cynthia McKinney, assault
a Capitol Hill police officer.
And nothing was done after that either.
So we've got to look at precedent.
We've got to have this conversation.
We have to address it.
And if we do a better job of holding ourselves
accountable, we can also hold the left accountable
as well.
We have to have that moral authority and that
means addressing some of these situations.
So, listen, if you if you need me to find
something positive about that, she does seem
to be saying that Marjorie Taylor Green is
crazy.
She is drawing false equivalencies to Maxine
Waters, though, and also saying this stuff
was said before Marjorie Green was elected
is not particularly relevant.
This is gaslighting.
This is what about ISM two side stuff and
it's a complete farce.
And at least she's admitting Marjorie Taylor
Green is crazy.
But Maxine Waters never followed around an
18 year old kid that was at a school during
a school shooting accusing that kid of wanting
to take her guns away, as Marjorie Taylor
Green did to David Hogg.
Maxine Waters never said that there were wild
fires started by, I don't know, Catholic space
lasers or anything like that.
And by the way, even if these examples from
the other side were equivalent there in the
past and they have nothing to do with Nancy
Mace and Republicans now dealing with Marjorie
Taylor Green, who is in her own party at this
point in time, Nancy Mace actually has a sort
of clever approach to a lot of these interviews.
I've seen other interviews where when Nancy
is asked what you would think or questions
she really has to answer, she'll sort of fast
talk through a bunch of distortions and lies.
It's sort of a Gish Gallop technique.
And very often anchors are interviewers even
either don't have the wherewithal or skill
to point it out or just don't have the time
because a lot of these segments last four
minutes.
It's hard to refute six lies in four minutes.
And Nancy Mace used very similar.
Talking points on CNN over the weekend, they
are terrible talking points, but she is getting
away with them.
And as I said before.
I am disgusted that Republicans, even with
these people, aren't just straight up calling
them out and saying there's no room for this
insanity in the Republican Party, obviously
it's disappointing they're not doing that.
I'm not surprised that they're not doing it.
But there is a political calculation happening
here where to some degree, I think they believe
the further they get from January 6th, the
further they get from Trump being in office,
the more they can kind of just shut their
mouths about these people and claim that they're
about legislation and they're about stopping
socialism and government takeover of health
care and reducing the deficit, all that stuff
that they pretend to care about and just sort
of not comment on people like Marjorie Taylor
Green, Lauren, Bobert, Madison, Cawthorn and
others.
So ultimately, I believe that the test as
to whether these radical new members of Congress
will become a significant part of the Republican
Party will be whether they get reelected in
2022.
Democrats do have a path to expelling these
folks from committee assignments, but it would
take Republicans to really be able to get
them out of the House of Representatives.
I don't expect that to happen.
We talked on the bonus show yesterday about
how there have only been five expulsions in
the history of the house.
Three of them were in the eighteen hundreds
against members who were straight up supporting
the Confederacy.
The other two were in the 20th century, was
one of them in the 21st.
The other two were in the modern political
era and they were four members of Congress
who had actually been convicted of crimes.
And so I am not optimistic at all that we
are going to see these folks expelled.
Of course, it says a lot about the Republican
Party that they're unwilling to really take
a stand against them.
But that's not particularly surprising to
me.
I'd be shocked if it were to you if you've
been paying attention to what has happened
to the Republican Party, even casually over
the last few years.
We will take a quick break.
Much more coming up in just moments.